[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 43rd episode of chess trap
series
in this episode i am going to show you a
wonderful
high profile counter trap in the london
system
from the white perspective now there are
various way you can reach to the
critical position
i am going to show you one of the way d4
d5 knight to f3 knight to f6
bishop to f4 and by far the most
aggressive response is
c5 okay e3
knight to c6 c3
and now one of the most popular and the
famous setup by black
starting with queen to b6
so black queen is attacking on b2 square
and if you check this position in online
database
white has exclusively played in the most
of the game
queen to b3 which has a very simple
idea that if black takes the screen
then he is going to retake with the a
pawn and then
open a file can be a good avenue
for the attack however
blackhand sets up a nice trap here
and even i have mentioned this trap in
my dirty chest tricks 26th episode
black has a very nice move in this
position
namely c4
so now it's the reverse case where white
really don't want to take the screen and
then give open file to the black rogue
so accordingly the many of the white
players has continued with
queen to c2 thinking that now we are
going to open the position
with b3 but unfortunately for white
black has a very nice move bishop to f5
a simple deflection move so that
if white foolishly take this bishop then
after queen captures b2
he is winning the rook and in fact this
is a completely winning position for
black
so that's not an option and sadly enough
there is nothing better in this position
namely queen to c7
but after that black can continue with
e6
and as you can see i have highlighted by
the arrows
black has a very simple plan queen to d8
and then start pushing this queen side
pawn forward
and white doesn't have good answer to
this
black score usually from this position
so this is the trap black sets up and if
you are white
you should certainly avoid it
so the big question arrives now how we
are going to defend the b2 pawn
well the answer is very simple you are
going to play
queen to c2 not only defending
but setting up a cunning counter trap
and i can't tell you how many people has
fallen into this
as they don't recognize the difference
between
queen to b3 and queen to c2 and they
think
that oh another big mistake by white
i am going to play bishop f5 so that
he can't take my bishop and then i will
steamroll him on the queen side
but the matter of fact is
it is now black who is asking for the
trouble
before i move on i like you to spot the
difference
and find out the key move which creates
a huge problem for the black camp
are you ready let's start the key move
here is
d capture c5
so the first thing first if black
captured the spawn
then we are more than happy to lop off
this
free piece as queen now cannot go to b2
unless black get two moves
so that's right out of the equation
and that means black response is force
he has to take this queen
after that we will take black queen
and now black has two choices
the first option a captures b6 which is
most oftenly played
which i consider is a dubious try by
black
as after the simple move knight to a3
not only we are attacking the bishop but
in the next turn
this knight will sit on this juicy b5
square
which can no longer harass by the black
pieces
for example if black continue with bad
moves such as
either bishop to f5 or bishop to g6
in that case after knight to b5
now you can see the dark side of this
whole transaction
not only black has some horrible pawn
structure on the queen side
but there is already a fork looming on
the c7 square
and to be honest it is very awkward for
the black camp
for example if he plays rook to c8 then
we have bishop to c7
and then there is a huge pressure on the
b6 pawn
and the second move king to d7 is
absolutely very bad
as y doesn't require much imagination
he can clearly continue with bishop e2
castle
centralizing the two roo and then hit
back with the c4
where black king can find himself in a
huge trouble
at the d-file so all in all
at this position black has to play
bishop to e4
so that when this dominating knight
comes to the b5 square
he can immediately chop it off
okay bishop captures b5
so the threat is very obvious we want to
play knight to e5
and actually from here onwards the fun
begins
for the white camp
well to show you how dangerous this
position is
i like to show you a model game where a
2200 rated opponent
crushed a 2000 plus rated opponent
in just mere 19 moves
in the game black stopped knight to e5
with
knight to d7 well now some natural moves
from the buddha side
castle on the king side e6
trying to liberate the last piece
rook to d1 bishop to e7
and black is just one move away from the
castle
but guess what white didn't even give
time for that he lash out with
c4
well there is no good way to defend d5
so black plays d capture c4
and now here white can play knight to d4
and get a good position
but i think he choose the more
aggressive response
starting with rook 27
black must be in a panic state as he
cannot castle on the king's side
and after rook to c4 the c6 knight comes
into the huge pressure so he decided
to castle on the queen side connecting
the rook
defending d7 but missing the important
tactic
that is rook capture c4
well how are you going to defend this
blackjuice knight to b8
more pressure with rook to c1
rook to d5 counter-attacking the bishop
but very calm and good counter attacking
reply
knight to d4 and if you look at this
position
black is really out of the move
no wonder black made the critical error
from this position
continuing with rook h2d8
but just one move and black resigned
i wonder if you can spot it
did you find it let's see
the star move is bishop captures be it
bam
well black simply resign in the view of
king takes b8 and now bishop captures c6
and you can't take this bishop because
after knight captures c6
you are getting the rook on the d8 and
if not
then white emerge with a clear piece
advantage
so i think this game is a moral
demonstration what happens
if white continue with a captures
b6
probably more tasting reply here is
bishop captures b1
rook captures b1 and now a captures b6
at least black is generating the
pressure on the a2 pawn
well not so surprising white has some
cunning trap here as well
starting with bishop to b5
inviting black to get a pawn on a2
well apart from it if black tries other
moves such as
e6 or knight to d7 then
white has a very simple reply a3
and with the two bishop pair and the
fracture pawn structure
this is definitely great advantage
to the white camp to cut the long story
short
black has to accept this pawn with rook
captures a2
and after that we are going to continue
with
knight to e5 so as you can
see there is no way black can defend on
c6
and even after the base sequence as per
the engine
rook to a5 attacking the bishop bishop
capture c6
pawn takes c6 knight takes c6 attacking
the rook
black can't play rook 28 because white
has a simple threat namely
king tweet when rook to even where this
lack of peace development on the king's
side
paid heavy price to the black cam so
accordingly
the best response here is rook to c5
after that we are going to continue with
knight to b4
so at first sight it looks like there is
nothing going on in this position
and white is slightly better but see
yourself
after e6 liberating the other bishop
white has this very nice move rook to
even
so penetration on the second rank is on
the card
and there are two ways black can respond
to this
number one if we continue with rook to
c8
which attack the knight well time being
we can put our knight back to d3
and now after some natural moves bishop
to e7 and rook to a7
number one black cannot castle on the
king side
number two white has a very simple plan
including king to e2 double the rook on
the a file
or maybe create pressure on the b7 file
all together if you check this position
in any engine
even though material is equal white is
clearly
winning
but some of you will ask what about rook
to e5
isn't that stop any nuisance on the file
well yes it can except it cost
a whole pawn for the black cam as after
the following sequence
rook captures e5 pawn takes a5
and now knight to c6 are tackling the
pawn
okay that guy is completely helpless
so he has to push on but after king to
e2
in the next turn rook is going to munch
that pawn
the best black can do over here is a3
separate of a pawn but nope he can't
take on a3
the simple reason is after rook to even
suddenly black find to his horror that
he is going to lose a piece
and in fact the game
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
wonderful counter trap against one of
the most aggressive setup by the black
remember play the move queen to c2
invite your opponent for bishop to f5 so
that
you can take on c5 and after the forcing
sequence
bishop capture c2 and pawn takes b6
no matter however black plays as
i have shown in this video with the
accurate play
it is white who has clearly better
chance
to get the full point thank you for
watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care